لم يلقى المبعوثان الاوروبي ميروسلاب لايت
شك والامريكي وجابرييل اسكوبار ما يسرهما
في كوسوفو فرئيس حكومتها لم يقبل بالتراجع
عما وصفاها بالخطوات الاحاديه غير
الضروريه بشان التوترات في البلديات
الصربيه
يقول المبعوث الامريكي ان الحلف الغربي
كله يواجه تحديات في علاقته ببرشتينا لان
رئيس وزرائها لا ينسق ولا يتعاون
جئت الى هنا داعما كبيرا لكسه نريد الافضل
لكسفه وان تحقق كل طموحاتها نحن اكبر داعم
لامنكم واستقلالكم وسيادتكم وكل ما نطلبه
ان نسمع
[تصفيق]
ثلاثه مطالب وضعها المبعوثان ان تخفض كسر
التصعيد بسحب عربات الشرطه هذه من
البلديات الصربيه ويعمل رؤساؤها من اماكن
بديله اعاده الانتخابات في اقرب وقت ممكن
وعوده البلدين الى الحوار الذي يرعاه
الاتحاد الاوروبي
قد تكون قرارات كسب قانونيه ولكنها ليست
شرعيه الانتخابات قاطعها كل الصرب لان
موقف بيلغراد هو تشكيل رابطه تعطي حكما
ذاتيا للبلديات ذات الاغلبيه الصربيه ثم
تعقد انتخابات نحن ضحايا الجانبين
كوسوفو لا تمانع في اجراء انتخابات جديده
والعوده الى الحوار مع صربيا لكنه ما
تختلفان في من يبادر كوسوفو تريد ان ينسحب
المحتجون اولا والمحتجون يريدون انسحاب
عربات الشرطه خلاف في التفاصيل يطيل امد
الازمه
هذا انقسام مصطنع وغير مرغوب لا يريده
الالبان ولا الصرب الانقسام السياسي ويحدث
اضطرابات في الحدود الاداريه لان ذلك ليس
في مصلحه احدهم
يمتنع الطرفان السربي والكوسوفي عن
المبادره فتسارع قوات حفظ السلام الى
ازاله هذه الاسلاك الشائكه لعل في ذلك ما
يخفف حده الاضطرابات في الظاهر على الاقل
التوترات الميدانيه هنا في بلديات الشمال
على وقع الضغوط الدوليه دون ان تتشكل
بالضروره ثقه متبادله بين صرب كوسوفو
وحكومتها فالاولويه الراهنه للاتحاد
الاوروبي والولايات المتحده هي تجنب اي
صراع جديد في اوروبا والمراهنه على مسار
الحوار وان كان طويلا وبطيئا محمد المدهون
الجزيره من بلده متروفيتسا شماليه كوسوفو